hoy en directo va Vamos a Argentina
porque el estado denunció penalmente a
la empresa Privada de energía edesur por
los reiterados cortes en el servicio que
han afectado a miles de personas en la
región metropolitana la situación se ve
agravada por la ola de calor que vive
Argentina desde hace semanas vamos a
conectar en Buenos Aires con natalio
cosoy corresponsal de France 24 natalio
por Cuáles cargos el gobierno está
denunciando a la empresa
Qué tal el interventor del ente
regulador de la electricidad Walter
martello publicó en su cuenta de Twitter
esos cargos de la denuncia es por
defraudación abandono de personas y
entorpecimiento de los servicios
públicos además el enre este órgano
regulador dijo hace dos días que elevará
el congreso un informe técnico en el
transcurso de los próximos 90 días para
que evalúe la posible caducidad de la
empresa de Sur que es una de las dos
empresas que operan la distribución de
la electricidad en la ciudad de Buenos
Aires y las zonas de sus alrededores en
el área metropolitana de Buenos Aires la
otra sdnor que ha sufrido muchos menos
cortes que de Sur la verdad que la
situación ha sido muy muy difícil en
estos días para los habitantes de la
ciudad de Buenos Aires y sus alrededores
bueno y justamente le pregunto por la
situación de las personas en el área
metropolitana de Buenos Aires cómo son
estos cortes que se están presentando
bueno en esta región además recordemos
vive más o menos un tercio de la
población de Argentina alrededor de 14
millones de personas los cortes algunos
son intermitentes algunos son muy
prolongados hay zonas hay hogares que
han tenido varios días seguidos una
semana seguida de cortes en general
intermitentes que provocan muchísimas
dificultades por ejemplo
desabastecimiento de agua cuando se
necesitan bombas que llenen los tanques
de agua problemas también con los
alimentos han tenido que descartar
alimentos porque se pudren no se pueden
conservar en las heladeras o en los
refrigeradores esto también por supuesto
afectado a muchísimos comercios
almacenes supermercados restaurantes
personas que además son
electrodependientes depende su salud de
la provisión de Electricidad también se
pudieron haber visto afectadas eso ha
generado muchísimo enojo muchísimas
reacciones ha habido protestas públicas
Incluso en las propias oficinas de
edesur